what's the address of the emergency  the address of emergency is 948 Cahuenga  Boulevard  and there's a man in a four-door BMW  and a great vehicle that's crashed  against the building  it's crushed  it's crap okay did it go into the  billionaires just hit the building no it  did not it's a question to the wall okay  and is is there any hazards like down  power lines cars on fire  fire hydrants was anybody thrown from  the vehicle that you can tell is anyone  in the vehicle anybody thrown from the  vehicle like ejected no is anybody  pinned or trapped  no okay is there any injuries  um are you are you there are you next to  the car or close  no I'm outside okay all right the fire  department's on the way to that location  sir are you able to get next to him no  sir I'm in my vehicle I'm just outside  there's other people trying to open the  car door and to get this gentleman out  okay the fire department's on the way  PDM 237 it'll be our incident 405.  thank you sir